I'm gonna take off in five seconds
have you ever seen long exposure
photography you probably know the shots
I'm talking about with the really sweet
light streaks across a frame well I've
always where to combine my love for
racing drones with this awesome
photography technique I am going to
attach some super bright LED lights to
the top of this drone and then gather my
photography buddies and go out to see
who can get the coolest looking shots
let's see if we could put a unique spin
on this classic photography technique
now before we really dive in to what
we're doing in this video I feel like I
should at least explain a little bit
about what exactly long exposure
photography is so the way taking the
photo actually works is that there's
this thing called a shutter think of it
as a literal door that opens to allow
your neighboring light photons to come
in and then closing again blocking them
in for life with long exposure
photography when a light moves it
doesn't just go away like it does in the
video it leaves behind a history of the
lights position in the form of a trail
all I got to do is decrease my shutter
speed that's the same as leaving the
door open longer for photons to enter
the sensor have you ever taken a blurry
photo that happens when the camera moves
while the picture is being taken but if
the camera is steady and you're moving
some lights you can get some really cool
looking streaks of light so just by kind
of winging it I got a 10 second exposure
that actually looks pretty solid now to
actually put it on a drone and test like
this so in order to get these lights
into the sky first you need a drone and
that's where this comes in this is a
five-inch propeller sized racing drone
and this is where I've been flying quite
a bit over the last year and this can do
flips this can do barrel rolls it can do
all kinds of crazy acrobatics that your
simple run-of-the-mill autonomous
operated drone can't really do now we
can actually precisely and very
accurately fly the shapes that we want
to do for these light paintings assuming
I can see and we'll get to that so the
goal is to attach both of these lights
to the top of this drone in a way that
doesn't add too much weight to the
overall lift so I did a video last year
where I put a 360 camera on top of this
drone and I still have that GoPro mount
on this thing I was actually really
inspired by the mounts of this light on
the camera
this is this little thing that clips on
to here like that so I decided to take
that principle and model these two
little crevasses for these two lights to
sit back to back on top of the drone on
top of the GoPro button so this is my
first iteration the main thing that
doesn't work is the fact that the lights
are not better secured I need a way to
solve that and the way I did that was by
printing a top piece here this piece
that's on top and acts like a clamp all
right I think I'm ready to actually test
this but in order to actually do that I
have to wait for nightfall I haven't
flown at night very much because when
I'm flying I've got these goggles on
this camera that I use to actually see
does not have great low-light
capabilities so that means I'm not gonna
be able to see very well when I'm flying
I'm having you know psych myself up for
flying blind before we actually do like
some real shoots with real photographers
I want to get a little bit more practice
flying around in the dark I think I'm
ready to fly this thing hopefully I
don't crash and liftoff and three two
I could totally see
Oh God Oh God Oh the only problem is
that I'm not getting nearly as much
light ahead of me to see as I thought
tomorrow I left playground I couldn't
see anything he was just like a black
boy I guess time to look at the actual
photos on my computer I managed to get I
don't know maybe a couple dozen shots
throughout the whole night so this is my
first attempt of the night you ready not
gonna lie I was pretty pleased with that
I love how the light actually
illuminates the ground in the play set
itself however the problem that I now
see is that anyone with the flashlight
could have gotten these shots I got to
go beyond the reaches of our arms to fly
around the tops of trees or up the sides
of buildings something that really
accentuates the fact that it's not a
person with the light tracing out the
outlines it's a drone it's really hard
to fly at night so I need a better way
to see where I'm flying so there's an
easy simple fix and that is to take my
light and rotate it 90 degrees sideways
I think this is an elegant solution I'll
have enough light to see where I'm
flying and also if I just keep in mind
where I'm flying in a better way I'll
get better looking shots I'm an OK pilot
like I can fly and do some cool tricks
and whatnot but I have a friend who is a
very good pilot his name is Steele Davis
and he is widely considered to be one of
the best pilots in the world Steele
actually helped us like 4 years ago with
our drone Star Wars video and Steele is
actually coming back tonight to fly with
us so I actually ended up a remodeling
this whole thing to work with his quad I
mean at the front of it he has like one
of these classic a little like pooped
GoPro things I basically just took
everything I liked about the top half of
my original design and incorporated in
the double tooth doohickey pen print so
I've updated the design and while I wait
for that to print I wanted to take a
moment to talk to you about something I
have found very inspirational and I
think it'll help you finish or even
start that project that you've been
thinking about for so long and that is
an audio book by Adam Savage
called every tools a hammer yes this is
a sponsored segment by audible but don't
skip ahead because you're gonna miss out
some pretty sweet life lessons Adam has
made thousands of projects in his life
and he'll be the first to tell you he
has screwed up a lot of them and he's
also very sure to point out that that's
okay because you can learn from your
failures realize what doesn't work and
then move on from it it doesn't apply to
just like building things in a workshop
it applies to the act of creating
anything I highly recommend getting this
book I think you might find as much
inspiration in it as I did and you can
actually download it for free along with
two audible originals by getting a 30
day trial to audible all you got to do
is go to audible.com such quarter krob
or simply text corridor crew to 500 500
again that's audible.com slash plurid or
crew or just text cord or crew to 500
500 I am a huge fan of audible I don't
have to say that I like talking about
things that I like the print is done the
design is final and tonight is the night
we launched a place called Devil's Gate
dam and I'm really hoping that the light
from this will illuminate all the really
cool architecture of the dam while
getting some cool lights tricks while we
do it
so the idea here is that Nick Jan and
Clint are each gonna use their own
cameras or try to get the coolest
looking long exposures shot while a
world class drone pilot flies around I'm
really hoping that everyone will bring
their own creativity to the table we're
here for a cool reason we're gonna take
some awesome long exposure shots
we're out of damn in Los Angeles haunted
damaged haunted so this is it flying
with a like a spotlight on the front if
there's things around to balance the
light off of then it's cool but if
there's not and you're just flying an
open space you can't see anything and
it's freakin terrifying
I'm excited man this is it the plan that
I see currently is that we'll just take
off fly until the batteries will low and
they come in for landing
you guys just capture whatever is then
up in the air alright I'm gonna sneak
off I'm gonna go up here
I'm trying it up a view of everything
yeah that's my goal hunts shooting down
on us exactly currently we have an a7 s3
which I'm a mess around with here the
clip has a Nikon and a a segment are you
rollin
how's it feel clan so it's not like
terrifying but the one thing is is he
going to remember where you what
orientation you're in because you're
doing based off visuals alone don't get
super disoriented because the ground is
all black you know I got a good couple
oh very cool yeah I'm gonna find out I'm
gonna try it I'll probably end up
strafing pointing at the hill is there
someone there I can't even see
that was scary that was those I want to
sit down turn out pretty cool
that is a dope frame I am setting up a
Wong's I shot of a beautiful damn-near
steel is going to do spirals up into the
heavens making a pretty cool look the
Steel's gonna try to fly the drone all
the way up and do the trench run up the
stairs
these are infinite stairs are you going
a little Dutch there I'm trying to get
artsy you getting some shots - there
Clinton barely it's just a bunch of but
trash taught but garbage this is like
being a National Geographic photographer
the Eagle like brushes you with this
wing yeah here comes again good one man
sweet yeah dude I think it's worth
waiting for that shot could you see Nick
when you're flying up the stairs there
yes I'm at the top fill its face like
coming in coming out I was like yeah
let's go to the other side
so I'm gonna stand here while steel does
some orbits around me because he's very
very good at doing orbits I am trusting
you to not run into me if I do hit you
I'll try to hit this thing yeah no this
has somebody padding in it I want to do
a faster orbit I'll try to get as many
one mores as I can
that is quite scary
[Music]
[Applause]
well still thank you so much for flying
this was a bit of a dream come true for
me because I knew I wouldn't be able to
pilot well enough to get some of these
shots where can we find you on the
Internet mr. Steele on YouTube and mr.
Steele FPV on instagram I just lied
drones and do car stuff now let's get
out of here it's cold we held the
shutter button down for a long time it's
good looks sick you're supposed to hold
the shutter button down Jan what was
your shutter speed friends gonna be so
mad like all three of these guys have
selected their best photos and they're
gonna display them up on the computer
screen for us all to review together
actually actually I I thought I got
garbage I got nothing but trash I was
like kind of down the whole day I can't
wait to see ya
first photo sweet look at the colors in
that man what we're seeing is actually
the exposed propellers being lit up by
the lights themselves I love this one
symmetry of this one it's a keeper for
sure Jin what would you edit I edit in
Lightroom sometimes in Photoshop but
mostly Lightroom Lightroom is great yeah
that's really cool I like the vignette
on your photos sure you're literally
capturing a circular image like these
next we're starting with the weird one
first this is like the fire you get to
go to like the EDM dance whoa whoa okay
I see the Dutch angle kind of threw me
there for a moment
I guess steel was doing a bunch of like
flippity-flop sand ones like the treble
clef this was what he was like flying up
through the railing I thought he was
gonna hit us the first past and I was
worried I bumped the camera when I
flinched because the wind was like I
have the opposite of this shot the
bottom yeah yeah maybe if someone said
more than five there's some great photos
what the Clinton got for us oh it's so
funny that I'm able to see each of you
guys's aesthetic styles Clint likes that
crunchy contrasts look
look at the light reflecting off of the
the bridge there oh and why don't one
can see the top of the bridge here I
like the symmetry that I like a lot this
is a pattern that I envisioned going
into this entire night shame shame I
wasn't waiting for you to do this
finally you did it and my plight
it's your initial sorry
looks like Wesley and West
I mean these are all great I'm glad you
guys came with me on this adventure I
think you got some amazing artwork out
of it we got a whole year ahead of us
we're gonna try to make a whole bunch of
cool content like this more adventures
more experiments more wacky things for
you guys to enjoy subscribe Clint took a
roll of film this night I try to get the
roll of film developed and they told me
that with this specific roll you're
gonna have to do it yourself this is a
film that Ren gave you for Secret Santa
it is and apparently it has a backing on
it that only I can develop myself we
should make a video about your journey
trying to develop your own film yeah
let's do it thank you for watching and
I'll see in the next video